avec l'arrivée du coc vie de 19 en
france et la montée de l'épidémie
les médecins spécialistes
épidémiologistes avait peu à peu
remplacer les experts politiques sur les
plateaux de télé une profusion
d'informations parfois mal maîtrisée
dont certains pays aujourd'hui
l'addition dans la longue liste des
médecins qui se sont exprimés les
premiers sur le coronavirus on ne peut
pas dire que michel cymes était aux
abonnés absents
très vite il s'est fait le porte parole
dans les médias des premières
constatations de grands spécialistes des
spécialistes pour lesquels début mars le
covin n'était pas alarmant ça reste une
maladie virale comme on en a tous les
ans sauf que voilà à force de parler de
sujets qu'on ne maîtrise pas toujours on
prend le risque de se tromper
c'est le cas de michel cymes qui a
d'abord expliqué que le covin n'était
pas très inquiétant avant de se raviser
quelques semaines après suite à la
montée de l'épidémie en france
aujourd'hui
l'orl le plus célèbre de france fait son
mea culpa et revient sur ses
déclarations on a probablement un peu
trop dit on sait avec on s'est basés sur
les expériences précédentes sur les
épidémies précédentes sur le virus on
s'est dit ressemblent à tel virus y va
faire la même chose je crois que cette
crise sanitaire va nous apprendre à dire
on sait pas toutefois pour lui c'est
d'abord son statut de star des médias
qui est en cause tu es en titre intel
premier à prendre le pavé dans la gueule
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus prudent il
intervient régulièrement sur rtl pour
informer les français et leur demander
de se protéger
bref il est loin le temps où le co vide
n'était qu'un virus étrangers essaie de
se défendre michel cymes et c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment il en prend plein la
gueule sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est vrai que quand nous mine de rien
on en a pris plein la gueule il n'a pas
été là pour me vendre aussi il ne
devrait lui pas enfoncé mais nous on
n'est pas au fait pas partie de ces
jours là on essaie d'aider les gens qui
sont dans la merde oui vallée oui enfin
moi je bravo et très bien moi je suis
pour tous les médecins qui disent j'ai
fait une bêtise jennings on demande
l'avis des téléspectateurs vie mohamed
par exemple a été un des premiers à dire
voilà j'ai peut-être minimisé il a été
excellent et je trouve d'ailleurs sur dû
me mohamed elle a été exceptionnelle je
dirais très fort et c'est pourquoi il va
faire des animaux à m mais là en
l'occurrence walla il dit il dit oh je
vais je voilà je fais mon mea culpa très
bien et bravo michel cymes de faire le
mea culpa n'y a que les imbéciles qui ne
disent pas quand ils ont fait des
bêtises
en revanche ce qui me gêne c'est qu'ils
recommencent derrière à dire que dans la
même phrase juste après il dit mais
pareils âge je ne vois pas arriver la
seconde vague mais tu ne sais pas donc
pourquoi tu recommences que tu viens de
faire tu ne sais pas si elle va arriver
ou pas donc on va après dans quinze
jours si la deuxième vague avis arrive
en temps michel cymes revenir sur le
plateau dire mea culpa peut-être que je
suis
je suis à marseille je n'aurais pas dû
parler de la seconde vague savoir si
elle sur un scénario sa jeunesse voilà
c'est à ce moment là tu dis coûter dans
l'état actuel des choses voilà ce que
l'on sait et voilà ce que je sais pas on
ne sait pas exactement bravo oui puis on
aime beaucoup mais son argument et son
argument force j'ai dû dire quand on est
on est dans la vitrine on connait le
premier à prendre le pavé dans la gueule
enfin personne l'a mis dans la vitrine
c'est lui qui s'y est mis dans la
vitrine beckett prudent il est médecin
nous conduisent des conneries mais ça
nous arrive très bas selon les rites il
s'était dit façon prémonitoire
c'est qu'une grille peut s'attendre du
moins d'en faire la plus que sous les
olé quand et médecin de formation je
pense qu'ils les voient la benjamine du
chômage je suis évidemment j'en doute
alors attention celle-ci mais c'est sur
intel attention on y va mollo il aimait
bien c'est léon jeu à tous sur tout par
cette période sans rigoler et après le
confinement et où elle prend encore 2
ans de confinement c'est la retraite un
des deux voies de films on la voit plus
loin explique c'est terminé c'est direct
de la place des lices à saint tropez
alors il a expliqué aussi qu'il a appelé
ceux qui l'ont accusé d'avoir parlé de
grippe est en expliquant qu'il n'avait
jamais minimiser ce point à ce point le
ver ici dit avoir appelé bruno masure ce
journaliste qui faisait le jt à l'époque
qui lui avait défoncé regarder pour
comprendre pourquoi il avait taillé la
paix il s'agit pas de minimiser mom a
reproché 25000 fouette minimes avaient
jusqu à d'autres mais c'est normal si on
en parle avec patrick thaler moi j'ai eu
bruno masure au téléphone parce qu'il
m'avait un peu taillé sur twitter je
vais aider mais qu'est ce que tu me
reproches et il me dit à parler de
grippette heures c'est sûr répète que je
n'ai jamais de prononcer le mot répète à
part pour dire ce en étant n'était pas
une mais bon passons
il m'a dit tu sais tu es en vitrine tu
es le premier à prendre le pavé dans la
gueule voilà c'est ce qu'a dit il avait
une grippe comme une autre alors eh ben
je vous dit on à l'archivé qui le mans
en galère c'était le 10 mars dernier
alors que l'épidémie commencé à prendre
de l'ampleur en france se regarder ce
qu'il avait dit michel cymes on répète
ça n'est pas une grippette parce qu'il y
avait un article disant que c'est pas un
rhume c'est une
une forme de grippe qui est un peu plus
cogner que la grippe mais ça reste une
maladie virale comme on en a tous les
ans et j'ai vu vos sujets tout à l'heure
où où on n'arrête pas de parler de
riester mais vous imaginez si tous les
ans à cheval qui a un ministre qui a la
grippe on fait une dépêche et puis on
fait tout ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
c'est dingue j'avais des ministres quand
la grippe et on le sait pas voilà qui
fait beaucoup parler qui dérange raymond
là dessus ouais c'est comme a dit
valérie c'est vrai qu'on s'est tous
plantés tout le monde s'est planté on
savait pas on avançait à vue ah ouais
moi je pense je pense qu'il a il s'est
rendu compte qu'il était personnes
étaient des français lui pendant
longtemps dans donc tout allait bien
pour lui légaux les sponsors il avait
signé chez machin et sécher et machin
qu'un sponsor de partout ils savent
c'est un cycliste
il faisait plus il faisait pu médecin il
était businessman il était dans les
médias est très bien pour lui il tombe
huit ans mohamed salah comme moi voilà
je suis en train de parler avec vous
aidant après je referai du camion s'est
très bien urbain sauf que là moi j'y
crois pas ses excuses pour moi il s'est
juste rendu compte que le vent tourne et
rer train de nous vendre une sauce et
puis voilà il s'en prend plein la tête
et c'est à juste titre et tu l'as dit
valérie luigi me mohamed s'était excusé
beaucoup de médecins sont excusés il a
été arrogant là il s'est rendu compte
vraiment quand les gens ne l'aiment pas
qu'est ce que ça fait
cela dit tout le monde s'est trompé il
met tout le monde s'est pas trompé c'est
pas un simple animateur ces deux
bailleurs cymes da le docteur car ils
ont la parole est importante et est
véridique
marc jacobs plus de confiance et
scientifique mais la raison et des
scientifiques maximiliano il parle entre
on parle en téléspectateur il a raison
ses docteurs mais normalement je serai
méfiant par rapport aux propos qui
devraient commencer demain c'est moi ou
la gaffe on y ont ils dit des conneries
importante a sorti une carte ils sont
nous ont pas dit on s'en fout à la basse
et or est partout ta carte regardez
c'est pratiquement la botte comme ça
qu'on excuse tous les médecins parce que
chacun fait se faisait ce qu'il pouvait
pour rassurer les gens on va mais
l'amendé comme a dit val il s'excuse et
après il reparle de la vague mais tu
n'en sais rien donc il ya un moment
donné où je pense que là faut que tout
le monde ferme sa bouche
on ne parle pas tant qu'on n'est pas sûr
fermer vos bouge parce que ça sert à
rien fait alors justement regarder
michel cymes qu'ici encore mouillée hier
il fait son mea culpa et ils seront
mouiller j'espère pour lui je vous le
dis qu'il n'y aura pas de deuxième vague
de froid
pour louise bourdeau voudrait moore lui
aussi parce que c'est vrai que là ça
commence à aa
j'aime je suis pas fan mais j'aime pas
qu'on sait trop
ouais tu l'as dit t'as même pas
l'acharnement
moi je ne vois pas venir la deuxième
vague vu justement les autres pays alors
vous vous dites qu effectivement en
allemagne on se demande si mais le
confinement était quand même bon et puis
il faut ifs
il faut aussi se dire que pendant des
mois on à en demander l'état a demandé à
imposer des choses aujourd'hui on
demande à chacun d'avoir sa propre
responsabilité
on n'est pas des enfants il faut que
chacun se sente responsable de lui et
surtout des autres et fasse attention et
c'est pas parce que on est en
déconfinement du faux à aller se balader
et se regrouper à 100 personnes
oui jean michel et lydie qui vois pas la
vague arriver il est gentil et pauvres
tellement il est aux arrêts lors qu'ils
n'entendent pas arrivés à la limite que
fit la guardia aura bien que lui les
journalistes et non pas comique merci